This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. In the spring of 1985, Bill Mora was wrapping up his high school education and getting ready to move to Pukipsy, New York. Come fall, he'd be starting his freshman year at Vassar College. Like many incoming college students, Bill was concerned about how he would pay for his education. My financial aid package in my freshman year was basically a combination of student loans and work study. But at the end of Bill sophomore year, he received an unexpected letter in the mail. I get this letter congratulating me
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。1985年春天，比尔·莫尔即将结束高中学业，准备搬往纽约州波基普西。到了秋天，他将在瓦萨学院开始他的大一生活。像许多刚入学的大学生一样，比尔很担心如何支付学费。我在大一时的经济援助组合基本上是学生贷款和勤工俭学的结合。但在比尔大二结束时，他意外地收到了一封信。我收到这封信，祝贺我
for receiving something called the Hager Scholars Award. And the letter explained that the award would take the place in my financial aid package of my student loan and here's what it said, this is an interest-free loan with a moral obligation to repay. So, you know, at the time I was like, what is that? I don't know what this is. I showed it to my mom. She's like, yeah, it's just a grant. You're fine, just take the money. But you know, I graduated, I went to graduate school, I became a professor, I paid off all my actual student loans, and when I had done so, I thought to myself, oh wait, I'm not done yet, there's that Hager award. And so, I like, you know, go online to look it up and I'm like, yeah, there it is.
获得了所谓的黑格学者奖。信中解释说，这笔奖学金将替代我经济援助方案中的学生贷款，信上是这样说的：这是一笔无需支付利息的贷款，并带有偿还的道德义务。所以，你知道，当时我就想，那是什么？我不知道这是什么。我把它拿给我妈妈看。她说，好吧，这只是一笔补助金。没关系，把钱拿着用吧。但你知道，我毕业了，读了研究生，成了一名教授，还清了所有真正的学生贷款，当我做完这些时，我心想，哦等等，我还没结束，还有那个黑格奖。所以，你知道的，我上网去查了一下，心想，好吧，它就在那儿。
Like, I have a moral obligation to repay. I better start repaying this thing. And that letter, that line, that thing about how, you know, you have a moral obligation, it caught me, it grabbed me and pulled me right in. The award made explicit, something that's often overlooked in the way we think about money. At its core, money is about human relationships. And at a macro level, loans and gifts and paychecks and the dollars that come out of ATMs are clues to a culture, even the structure of a nation.
就像，我有一种偿还的道德义务。我最好开始偿还这笔钱。而那封信、那句话、关于你有一种道德义务的那种说法，深深地吸引了我，抓住了我，把我直接拉了进去。这个奖项明确表达了我们看待金钱方式中经常被忽视的一点。金钱的核心，是人与人之间的关系。而在宏观层面上，贷款、礼物、薪水以及从自动取款机里吐出来的钞票，都是一个文化甚至是一个国家结构的线索。
So far in our Money 2.0 series, we've looked at the scripts we follow when it comes to money and the traps we fall into when it comes to budgets. Today we ask, where does the value of money come from in the first place? This week on Hidden Brain, we revisit a 2020 episode about the intangible elements of cold, hard cash. Coins in currency are not just tokens of economic value, but markers of emotional connection and shared history. There's a story we tell about what the world looked like before we invented money. It's a story built on the idea of butter. This is the standard story that we read in the economics textbooks and that has been
到目前为止，在我们的“金钱2.0”系列中，我们探讨了我们在金钱问题上遵循的脚本，以及我们在预算问题上陷入的陷阱。今天我们要问：金钱的价值最初究竟来自哪里？本周的《隐藏的大脑》节目中，我们再次回顾了一期2020年的节目，探讨冷冰冰的硬现金背后的无形元素。硬币和货币不仅仅是经济价值的符号，更是情感联系和共同历史的标志。关于我们发明金钱之前世界是什么样子的，流传着这样一个故事。这是一个建立在物物交换观念之上的故事。这是我们在经济学教科书中读到的标准故事，自19世纪中期甚至更早以来，它就已经
handed down to us at least since the mid 19th century if not before. This again is anthropologist Bill Morer, who told us the story of his moral obligation to repay that student loan. He's now the dean of the School of Social Sciences at the University of California Irvine, and he studies the origins and nature of money. And it goes something like this. In the beginning, before there was money, if I had something that you needed, I would approach you with that thing
流传至今。这位再次是人类学家比尔·莫尔，他给我们讲述了关于他偿还学生贷款的道德义务的故事。他现在是加州大学尔湾分校社会科学学院的院长，他研究金钱的起源和本质。故事大致是这样的。在最初，在没有金钱的时候，如果我有什么东西是你需要的，我会带着那个东西去找你，
and see if you had anything that I needed. So if you wanted some fish and you needed some acorns and I had them, I could approach you with those acorns and we could basically barter on the spot, figuring out how many acorns equals how many fish. The problem with barter is it really does depend on us each meeting each other's needs in that moment. And so the origin story of money that we have is that humans invented money essentially to be a mediator in these sorts
看看你有没有什么东西是我需要的。所以，如果你想要一些鱼，你需要一些橡子而我有，我就可以带着这些橡子去找你，我们基本上就可以当场进行物物交换，算出多少橡子等于多少鱼。物物交换的问题在于，它确实取决于我们双方在那个时刻正好满足彼此的需求。因此，我们所拥有的金钱起源故事是，人类发明金钱本质上是为了在这些类型的
of exchanges. In other words, if you, for example, had acorns, but I didn't actually want acorns, I wanted pots, for example, and I wanted to trade my fish for pots, and all you had to offer me was acorns. Then essentially, we couldn't negotiate. And economists sometimes have a term for this. They say that butter requires something called a double coincidence of wants. What is that? The double coincidence of wants essentially means that in that moment, I've got what you need. You've got what I need. There's a coincidence of our needs in the instance.
交换中充当调解人。换句话说，如果你，比如说，有橡子，但我实际上并不想要橡子，我想要锅，例如，我想用我的鱼换锅，而你唯一能提供给我的就是橡子。那么本质上，我们就无法谈判。经济学家有时对此有一个术语。他们说物物交换需要一种叫做“需求双重巧合”的东西。那是什么？需求双重巧合本质上意味着在那一刻，我有你需要的东西。你有我需要的东西。我们的需求在那一瞬间碰巧重合了。
And that rarely happens, right? So the idea here is that humans wizard up this kind of third thing, money, this magical substance that can put all things on one scale of value, and use that as sort of their measuring stick then to make these kinds of transactions. So there's a problem with the story, and the problem is that it runs into some facts. I'm wondering if you can tell me about the work that you and other anthropologists have done, for example, in the Highlands of New Guinea, that call into question this origin story. The problem is that when we look around the world and in the historical and archeological record,
这种情况很少发生，对吧？所以这里的想法是，人类凭空创造出这种第三种东西——金钱，这种神奇的物质，它可以把所有东西放在一个价值天平上，然后以此作为他们的衡量标准来进行这类交易。所以这个故事有个问题，问题在于它与一些事实相冲突。我想知道你能否告诉我，你和其他人类学家所做的工作，例如在新几内亚高地的工作，是如何对这个起源故事提出质疑的。问题是，当我们放眼世界以及历史和考古记录，
for instances of this kind of direct barter, unfortunately, we don't find it. What we find instead really are systems where people are taking some kind of object, let's take a kind of a big shell valuable in the Highlands of New Guinea, and using it to mark relationships. They're using it to mark relationships among people, among kin that serve as a kind of indicator of enduring obligations that people have to one another. It's kind of like an open-ended IOU, right?
寻找这种直接物物交换的实例时，不幸的是，我们找不到。我们真正发现的其实是这样一种系统：人们使用某种物体，比如在新几内亚高地用一种大型贝壳贵重物品，来标记关系。他们用它来标记人与人之间、亲属之间的关系，这可以作为人们彼此之间承担持久义务的一种指标。这有点像一个无期限的欠条，对吧？
If I give you this big shell thing, then that implies for us, but also for everyone around us, that we have a bond, we have a relationship that will essentially allow us to have a flow of goods between each other and between our families for the rest of our lives, essentially. So it's not so much that I'm giving you this shell so that you give me some pigs. It's I'm giving you this shell so as to say, hey, someday I'm going to need some pigs. Some other day I might need your help in the field. Some other day you might need me to help you out with something.
如果我把这个大贝壳给你，那么这对于我们，以及对于我们周围的所有人来说，就意味着我们之间有一种纽带，我们有一种关系，它本质上将允许我们在我们余下的生命中，在彼此之间以及在我们的家庭之间实现货物的流动。所以，与其说我把这个贝壳给你是为了让你给我一些猪，不如说我把这个贝壳是为了说明：嘿，总有一天我会需要一些猪。另一天我可能需要在田里得到你的帮助。再过一天，你可能需要我帮你的忙。
This shell kind of marks that relationship. It signifies to everyone around us that we have these ties of enduring obligation and responsibility. So, in other words, it's not about a transaction, at least not an immediate sense, it's about a transaction that perhaps unfolds over time more to do with obligation. My son is marrying your daughter, I'm giving you this precious necklace that I have and my expectation is over the next 20 years, our families are going to help one another in all kinds of ways.
这个贝壳某种程度上标志着这种关系。它向我们周围的所有人表明，我们拥有这种持久义务和责任的纽带。所以，换句话说，这无关乎交易，至少在即时意义上不是，这关乎一种也许随着时间推移而展开的、更多与义务有关的交易。我的儿子要娶你的女儿，我把这件我珍藏的项链交给你，我的期望是，在未来20年里，我们的家庭将以各种方式互帮互助。
That's right, it's really a memory device to indicate an ongoing enduring relationship and an ongoing set of obligations. And is some of this connected with the more basic idea, if you will, of just gift giving? When you think about gifts, part of what we're doing, when I'm giving you a gift, and presumably this is true for people all over the world in different cultures, the gift is partly my telling you here something nice for you, but it also binds us in some kind of relationship that says, down the line, you know, it's not explicit,
没错，它实际上是一个记忆设备，用来表明一种正在进行的、持久的关系和一组持续的义务。这是否与更基本的赠礼想法有关呢？当你想到礼物时，我们正在做的一部分事情是，当我送你一件礼物时，想必世界各地不同文化中的人们也是如此，这份礼物部分上是我在对你诉说“这里有些好东西送给你”，但它也以某种关系将我们绑定在一起，这种关系表明，在未来，你知道，这不是明文规定的，
but there's some implicit understanding that you're going to do something nice for me down the road. This is exactly how it works. Yeah, and the early anthropologist Marcel Mos wrote about this quite explicitly, saying that in the gift there's the obligation to give, there's the obligation to receive, but then also the obligation to reciprocate. This obligation to reciprocate can be seen across human societies and across time. Some years ago, Bill stumbled on another interesting example of this. He was in Washington, DC, visiting a colleague who worked at the Smithsonian.
但有一种内蓄的理解，即你在未来也会为我做一些好事。这正是它的运作方式。是的，早期人类学家马塞尔·莫斯对此做过非常明确的论述，他说在礼物中包含着赠送的义务、接受的义务，但随后还有回礼的义务。这种回礼的义务可以在整个人类社会和岁月中看到。几年前，比尔偶然发现了另一个有趣的例子。他当时在华盛顿特区，拜访了一位在史密森尼学会工作的同事。
She curated the museum's collections that relate to the history of money. Bill was with her inside a vault. And there's an area in the vault, in a kind of long closet. And she and her interns call it Narnia because it's sort of like the wardrobe and Narnia you go in and it goes on and on and on forever. Inside this Narnia, there are boxes upon boxes of uncatalog artifacts. So I was there once with her and she said to me, do you want to go to Narnia? And I said, sure. So we go in, pull out a box at random, bring it out. She opens the box and there's a ton of these clay tablets covered in kuneiform. And there's a sort of moment where both of us back away from
她负责管理博物馆中与货币历史相关的藏品。比尔和她一起在一个金库里。金库里有一个区域，在一个类似长衣帽间的地方。她和她的实习生们称之为“纳尼亚”，因为它有点像《纳尼亚传奇》里的衣柜，你走进去，它就没完没了地一直延伸下去。在这个“纳尼亚”里面，有成箱成箱未编目的文物。所以有一次我和她一起在那里，她对我说：“你想去纳尼亚吗？”我说：“当然。”于是我们走进去，随机抽出一个箱子，把它拿出来。她打开箱子，里面有大量刻有楔形文字的泥板。当时我们俩都有一个瞬间，从
the box. You know, and I'm like, oh, don't touch anything, don't break anything, don't breathe. The clay tablets that they pulled out of the box were used 5,000 years ago in ancient Mesopotamia. They were used to keep records of obligations. When people lived in small groups, monitoring obligations was easy. I just remembered what you had said and done, and you remembered what I had said and done. But as human societies grew larger, people needed a way to systematically keep track of who owed what to whom.
箱子旁退了开来。你知道的，我心想，别碰任何东西，别弄坏任何东西，别呼吸。他们从箱子里拿出的泥板是5000年前在古代美索不达米亚使用的。它们被用来记录义务。当人们生活在小群体中时，监督义务是很简单的。我只记得你说过的话和做过的事，你也记得我说过的话和做过的事。但随着人类社会的规模越来越大，人们需要一种系统化的方式来追踪谁欠了谁什么。
And we just can't keep track of all of that in our heads. What emerges essentially are systems of public administration where you've got centralized authorities who are responsible for organizing irrigation, organizing production so that you can have these larger scale settlements, who set up systems of record keeping in the case that you mentioned in Mesopotamia using clay tablets, so that people basically know what's going on, who's doing what, who owes what to whom. And you don't have the situation of something like a coin circulating from hand to hand to pay your laborers, for example.
而我们无法把所有这些都记在脑子里。基本上浮现出来的是公共行政系统，在这里你有集中的权力机构，他们负责组织灌溉、组织生产，以便你们能够拥有这些更大规模的定居点，他们建立记录保存系统——就像你提到的美索不达米亚使用泥板的情况——以便人们基本上知道发生了什么，谁在做什么，谁欠了谁什么。而且你不会遇到诸如一枚硬币在人与人之间流通来支付你的工人的情况，例如。
Instead, you have these systems of tablets that are basically receipts, keeping track of things like labor, and then promising that, you know, after a certain period, if the labor has been done, the laborer is entitled to X. In a lot of our ancient Mesopotamian receipts, it's things like beer and grain and livestock. And it's just unbelievably magical to see these materials, right? And then to imagine the system that created them and the systems that they supported, it's really quite an incredible thing to just put yourself back into that world, into a world that's so alien from the kind of system of market-based society that we live in today and think about what it would be like to be that scribe
相反，你拥有这些基本上是收据的泥板系统，追踪诸如劳动力之类的事情，然后承诺，你知道的，在一段时期之后，如果劳动力已经完成，劳动者就有权获得X。在我们许多古代美索不达米亚的收据中，都是啤酒、谷物和牲畜之类的东西。看到这些材料真是不可思议地神奇，对吧？然后想象创造它们的系统以及它们所支持的系统，把自己重新置于那个世界，置于一个与我们今天生活的基于市场的社会系统如此迥异的世界，去想象成为那个书吏会是什么感觉，
or to be the person who is, you know, asking the scribe to write this tablet or to be, you know, the common person whose whole life is subjected to a kind of organization or production in a system of centralized administration based on these written records, based on writing. This isn't a market the way that we traditionally understand markets, right? It's not sort of the idea that people come together in a place and exchange goods either by barter or by money. This is much more a kind of hierarchical system of organization to essentially allow for the creation of these larger-scale societies. So you've talked about this idea of centralized administration, and in some ways this brings
或者成为那个要求书吏写这块泥板的人，或者成为那个普通人——他的一生都服从于某种组织或生产，服从于一个基于这些书面记录、基于文字的中央集权行政系统。这不是我们传统理解的市场，对吧？它不是那种人们聚集在一个地方通过物物交换或金钱交换货物的想法。这更像是一种等级森严的组织系统，其本质是为了允许更大规模社会的创建。所以你谈到了中央集权行政的概念，在某些方面这把我们
us to another aspect of our story. We've talked a little bit about the idea of gift-giving and mutual obligations. We've talked about the idea of receipts and record-keeping and essentially basic contracts that sort of bind us to one another over time. the idea of receipts and record keeping and essentially basic contracts that bind us to one another over time. But talk also about this idea of the central administration of these systems and the introduction of what eventually become authorities that basically are overseeing how the whole system works.
带到了我们故事的另一个方面。我们讨论了赠送礼物和相互义务的概念。我们讨论了收据和记录保存的概念，以及本质上将我们彼此长期绑定的基本合同的概念。关于收据和记录保存的概念，以及本质上将我们彼此长期绑定的基本合同的概念。但同时也谈谈这些系统的中央集权管理的想法，以及最终成为监督整个系统如何运作的权威机构的引入。
So, to make a money work, you need something that is both that system of reckoning and record keeping, but also an authorizing power that says, in effect, this is the way that we keep our records here. So even in the Highlands of New Guinea, and then again in Mesopotamia, you've got both of those things going on, the system of record keeping and the authorizing force. And that's essentially what we have with modern money still today. We don't necessarily think of it that way. But basically money is a unit of account that in our case is authorized by the state.
因此，要让货币发挥作用，你需要一种既是那种清算和记录保存系统，同时又是一个授权权力的东西，它实际上在说：这就是我们这里保存记录的方式。所以，即使在新几内亚高地，然后又在美索不达米亚，你都同时拥有这两样东西：记录保存系统和授权力量。这本质上也是我们今天的现代货币所拥有的。我们不一定那样看待它。但基本上货币是一个记账单位，在我们的例子中，它是由国家授权的。
The state essentially sets the standard, and then that standard is used by people to reckon their relationships with one another another figure their debts and credits. So the story that emerges about the origins of money is very different in the way we usually think about it. In this model embraced by Bill and other anthropologists, money is partly a mechanism of social obligation and partly a mechanism to keep track of who owes what to whom. It's also a mechanism that cements the relationship between ordinary people and authorities who maintain records.
国家本质上设定了标准，然后人们使用该标准来计算彼此之间的关系，计算他们的债务和信用。因此，关于货币起源的故事与我们通常的想象非常不同。在比尔和其他人类学家所接受的这种模型中，货币部分是社会义务的机制，部分是追踪谁欠谁什么的机制。它也是巩固普通民众与维护记录的当局之间关系的机制。
In other words, it's a story about power. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. You've heard the old joke. Nothing is certain except death and taxes. Now, taxes may feel inevitable to us, but they were not always a part of human existence. Bill Moro says, systems of taxation emerged as societies expanded and became more complex.
换句话说，这是一个关于权力的故事。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。你听过那个老笑话吗？除了死亡和税收，没有什么事是确定的。现在，税收对我们来说可能感觉是不可避免的，但它们并非一直都是人类生存的一部分。比尔·莫尔表示，随着社会的扩张和变得更加复杂，税收系统应运而生。
So in most of these systems, what you see is the development of something like attacks or a tribute or a tithe, where a thing is sort of put out into the world, it can start off with just being, you know, grain or something like that. But often what happened in ancient societies is rulers would take something that symbolize
因此，在大多数这些系统中，你看到的是类似于税收、贡品或什一税的发展，即把某种东西投放到世界上，它可能最初只是，你知道的，谷物或类似的东西。但古代社会经常发生的情况是，统治者会拿走某种象征着
their own elite status, usually precious metal, and send some of it out into the world and say here, you get this in exchange for serving in my army, or you get this as a token to hold on to, to remind you that you are subject to my rule. And in return, on some regular cycle every year, every seven years, you are expected to bring some of that back to me to demonstrate your field to demonstrate your loyalty. And in effect, what we get is the origin of the first coins, things that look like coins
他们自己精英地位的东西，通常是贵重金属，将其中的一部分发送到世界上并说：“给你，你因为在我的军队服役而换取了这个，或者你得到这个作为留作纪念的代币，提醒你是受我统治的臣民。”作为回报，在每年、每七年的某个定期循环中，你被期望将其中一部分带回给我，以展示你的忠诚，展示你的效忠。实际上，我们得到的是第一批硬币的起源，这些东西对你我来说看起来像硬币，
to you and me, that are really serving as these kind of political tokens that express sovereignty. So I would get one of these things, and then I'm obligated at some point to get one of them or some of them back to you, that instantly creates a market in these things. Everybody has to get their hands on these new tokens of political authority in order to give some back to the center. So what's interesting is if I am a king and I'm basically saying, you not only need to pay me taxes,
但实际上它们充当了这种表达主权的政治代币。所以我会得到其中一件东西，然后我有义务在某个时候将其中一件或几件交还给你，这瞬间就在这些东西中创造了一个市场。每个人都必须弄到这些政治权力的代币，以便将一部分交还给中心。所以有趣的是，如果我是一个国王，我基本上是在说：你不仅需要向我纳税，
but you need to pay me these taxes using my tokens, using my system of currency. The currency not only gains value because of course people are now trading the currency and doing things with it and involving transactions, but it also sort of binds them to me and establishes my power over them because that's, I'm basically saying this is the language in which transactions can take place and that's extraordinarily powerful.
而且你需要用我的代币、用我的货币系统来向我纳税。货币不仅因为人们现在交易货币、用它做事并参与交易而获得了价值，而且它还某种程度上将他们绑定到我身上并确立了我对他们的权力，因为那就是——我基本上是在说这就是交易可以进行的语言，这具有非凡的力量。
It's unbelievably powerful and it's sort of the invisible power of the king in that sense. You can see this invisible power of the state each year when it comes time to file our tax returns. In the United States, citizens are obliged not only to pay taxes, but also to figure out how much they owe. Here's a sketch from the social media platform TikTok about this idea. Yes, you actually owe us money, it's called taxes. Okay, how much money do I owe you guys? Actually, you have to figure that out. Okay, so I can just like pay whatever I want. Well, not exactly.
这有着难以置信的力量，从某种意义上说，这是国王无形的力量。每到报税季，你都能看到国家这种无形的力量。在美国，公民不仅有纳税的义务，还要自己计算欠税金额。以下是社交媒体平台TikTok上关于这个想法的一个小品。是的，你实际上欠我们钱，这叫税。好的，我欠你们多少钱？实际上，你得自己算出来。好吧，那我就可以随便付我想付的钱喽？嗯，不完全是。
Like, we know like the exact number of how much you owe, but you also have to figure it out. Well, what if I mess up and get the number wrong? You, uh, you got a prison. That's hilarious. So, talk about this idea of Bill, which is that some ways, this is how many Americans feel about that taxes. What does this tell us in some ways about the nature of Bill, which is that some ways this is this is how many Americans feel about that taxes What is this tell us in some ways about the nature of money power and the state?
比如，我们知道你欠多少钱的准确数字，但你也得自己算出来。好吧，如果我把数字弄错了会怎么样？你，呃，你得坐牢。这太搞笑了。那么，比尔，谈谈这个想法吧——在某种程度上，这就是许多美国人对税收的看法。在某种程度上，这向我们揭示了关于金钱、权力和国家的本质的什么信息？
Yeah, well, you know, it's sort of right out there, isn't it that you know It's sort of on you to report your income and if you do it wrong or you know don't quite get it right We're gonna come after you through an audit or something. It really does kind of elevate the power of the state above us mere mortals. And again represents the authority of the state has both in terms of the standard of account or money and in terms of daily affairs having to do with that money. So one of the interesting things to consider here is that they might be actually different competing ideas about the nature and origin of money. One of them says it's transactional, it's functional, this is sort of what you learn in economics 101. The model that you're painting is that this is much more about relationships and mutual obligations and histories of those obligations and how those are
是的，好吧，你知道，它就明摆在那里，不是吗？你知道，上报你的收入是你的责任，如果你弄错了或者，你知道，没有完全弄对，我们会通过审计或其他方式来找你算账。这确实将国家权力提升到了我们这些凡人之上。并且再次展现了国家在记账标准或金钱方面以及在与该金钱有关的日常事务中所具有的权威。因此，这里需要考虑的有趣事情之一是，关于金钱的本质和起源，实际上可能存在着不同的相互竞争的观点。其中一个观点认为它是交易性的、功能性的，这基本上就是你在经济学101中学到的。而你所描绘的模型则是，这更多地关乎关系和相互义务、这些义务的历史以及这些历史如何随着时间被记录和保存，以及可能参与保存它们的国家权威及其与你的关系等等。我想知道你是否能谈谈，当这些不同的系统——如果你愿意的话——彼此发生冲突时会发生什么。你谈到过，当欧洲殖民者去到非洲和亚洲时，在某种程度上他们遇到了与他们习惯的不同系统，在某种程度上，你所遇到的不仅是人的冲突、文明的冲突，还有在这些接触中如何定义什么是真正金钱的冲突。是的，欧洲人一直错误地将世界各地诸如
recorded and preserved over time and the state authorities that might be involved in preserving them and their relationship to you and so forth. I'm wondering if you can talk a little bit about what happened when these different systems, if you will, clashed with one another. You've talked about how when European colonists went to Africa and Asia, in some ways they encountered different systems and the ones they were used to, and in some ways you had not just a clash of people and a clash of civilizations, if you will, but a clash of how you define what money actually is during these encounters. Yeah, Europeans consistently misidentified things like
贝壳、金属棒或手镯之类东西误认为他们习惯的那种金钱。那他们会怎么做呢？好吧，他们会做的一件事就是强行引入他们自己的标准，这是撒哈拉以南非洲地区殖民和征服的一种典型手段，即要求被殖民的人民用欧洲货币纳税，这意味着他们必须获得那种欧洲货币，
shells or metal rods or bracelets and things like that around the world as the kind of money that they were used to. And so what would they do? Well, one thing that they would do is they would forcibly introduce their own standard, that's kind of a typical means of colonization and subjugation in Sub-Saharan Africa, was to demand that colonized people pay taxes in European money, that then meant that they had to get that European money,
这意味着他们将不得不做一些事情，比如种植庄稼、出售东西或从事奴隶贸易之类的事情，以产生他们可以交回的货币。或者在其他情况下，欧洲列强只需通过以下方式重置标准：你知道，以前这些贝壳很好，但这个别的贝壳更好，我们要用这另一种贝壳征税。
which meant that they would have to do things like grow crops or sell things or engage in the slave trade or something like that that would generate that money they could give back. Or in other cases, European powers would just reset the standard by saying, you know, these shells before were good, but this other shell is better, and we're going to demand our taxes in this other shell.
同样，再次在这些其他贝壳中建立一个市场，这随后完全扭曲了遭受殖民统治的社会。所以这很有趣。金钱在某种程度上是殖民化的工具。绝对是的。我认为金钱一直是政治权力的工具。比尔说，政治权力不仅来自于发行货币，还来自于设计货币的行为。你在纸币或硬币上看到的形象可以很大程度上说明一个国家的价值观和抱负。2015年，财政部长邀请比尔和其他学者前往华盛顿特区。他们将讨论对10美元纸币重新设计的提议。
Again, similarly, setting up a market in these other shells, which then completely contorted the societies that were subject to colonial rule. So it's interesting. Money in some ways was a tool of colonization. Absolutely. I think money has always been a tool of political authority. Bill says political authority is drawn not just from issuing money, but from the act of designing it. The images you see on a bill or a coin can say a great deal about the nation's values and aspirations. In 2015, the Treasury Secretary invited Bill and other scholars to Washington DC. They would have discussed a proposed redesign of the $10 bill.
我被邀请去参加一个头脑风暴会议，讨论可以做些什么，什么样的历史人物是合适的，什么样的图像符号对于新纸币是合适的。这真的很像一个研究生研讨会。我们只是进行了广泛的交谈，谈论美国的女性历史、奴隶制和解放的历史以及民权运动，谈论你可以在纸币上做的事情，关于这个国家你可以在金钱上讲述的故事，以及这些故事如何能让人们以一种新的方式在这个国家感到自己被包容。
I was invited to come and just have a kind of brainstorming session about what could be done, what sorts of figures would be appropriate, what sorts of iconography would be appropriate for the new banknote. And it really was like a kind of graduate seminar. We just kind of had a wide-ranging conversation about women's history in the United States, about the history of slavery and emancipation and the civil rights movement, and about the kinds of things that you could do on a bank note, the kinds of stories that you could tell on the money about the nation and the ways those stories could make people feel included in the nation in a new way.
再次强调，这发生在2015年。那正是音乐剧《汉密尔顿》在百老汇首演的同一年。这提醒了每个人亚历山大·汉密尔顿在建立我们的银行系统中所起的作用。目前10美元上的人物是亚历山大·汉密尔顿，然后我们想也许我们想留住他。因此，比尔和团队决定，与其重新设计10美元纸币，他们应该更新20美元纸币。因为20美元是一张更无处不在的纸币，它是所有自动取款机里都会吐出来的钱。
Again, this was happening in 2015. That was the same year that the musical Hamilton debuted on Broadway. And it reminded everyone of the role that Alexander Hamilton played in establishing our banking system. The figure on the ten currently is Alexander Hamilton and then we thought maybe we want to keep him. So Bill and the group decide that instead of redesigning the ten dollar bill, they should update the twenty. Since the twenty is a more ubiquitous banknote, it's the one that comes out of all the ATMs.
它比10美元更常出现在人们的日常交易中。美国第七任总统安德鲁·杰克逊的肖像自1928年以来一直印在20美元纸币上。杰克逊的任期以签署《印第安人迁移法案》为标志，该法案导致了数千名原住民的死亡。比尔和华盛顿小组的其他成员认为应该由一位女性来取代杰克逊。他们倾向于地下铁路的一位英雄。围绕哈莉特·塔布曼存在着非常强烈的共识，部分原因是因为让她的肖像出现在纸币上将有助于勾勒并完善关于美国社会的叙事弧光，关于扩大选举权、关于解放、
It's much more common in people's daily transactions than the 10. The image of Andrew Jackson, the seventh president of the United States, has been on the $20 bill since 1928. Jackson's tenure was marked by the signing of the Indian Removal Act, which resulted in the deaths of thousands of indigenous people. Bill and other members of the group in Washington felt a woman should take Jackson's place. They gravitated toward a hero of the Underground Railroad. There was really strong consensus around Harriet Tubman, in part because having her on the bill would help to sort of sketch and then complete a story arc about American society, about increasing the franchise, about emancipation,
关于民权运动。让我们所有人都非常兴奋的事情之一是，时任美国财政部长罗茜·里奥斯传阅了她最喜欢的纸币，也就是2美元纸币。她把它传阅开来让我们看。她说：“看看背面。”我们看着背面。与其他所有美国纸币不同，2美元纸币背面有一个场景。上面有人们站在一起签署《独立宣言》。
about the civil rights movement. And one of the things that got all of us very excited was when the then-treasurer of the United States, Rosie Rios, passed around her favorite bank note, which is the $2 bill. And she passed it around for us to look at. And she's like, take a look at the back. We look at the back. Unlike all of the other American bank notes, the $2 bill has a scene. It has people standing together, signing the Declaration of Independence.
她说：“你知道的，如果你用人物激活纸币的背面，你能做些什么呢？”然后我们的脑海开始围绕这个想法飞速运转。你可以使用5美元纸币，正面保留林肯，背面保留林肯纪念堂，但在上面填满民权游行队伍，以及一个小小的正在发表“我有一个梦想”演讲的马丁·路德·金或类似的东西。有一点我想我们
And she said, you know, what can you do if you activate the back of the note with people? And then our minds kind of went racing around that idea. You could have the $5 bill, keep Lincoln on the front, keep the Lincoln Memorial on the back, but populate it with the Civil Rights March and a tiny little Martin Luther King giving his, I have a dream speech or something like that. There was a point where I think we
变得有点太兴奋、太有创意了，财政部长说：“你知道的，请记住，这东西上的房地产（版面）是有限的，设计师能做的事情也是有限的，别忘了所有防伪的东西也必须放进去。”所以，有那么几个时刻，她说：“好了，大家冷静点，太有创意了。我们不会在纸币上搞一本图形小说。”但这就是我们的思路，因为我们开始思考所有你可以在这个东西上讲述的故事，它确实仍然是美国最无处不在的大众媒体形式之一。
got a little too excited and too creative and the treasurer said, you know, bear in mind, there's a limited amount of real estate on this thing and there's only so much that designers can do and don't forget that all of the counterfeit detection stuff has to go in there too. So like, there are a few moments where she's like, okay, settle down people, too creative. We're not going to have a graphic novel on the bank note. But that's kind of really where our minds went because we started thinking about all of the stories that you can tell on this thing that really is still one of the most ubiquitous forms of mass media in the United States.
关于20美元纸币重新设计的公告于2016年4月发布。通过地下铁路帮助300多名奴隶重获自由的哈莉特·塔布曼将成为20美元纸币的新面孔。塔布曼将是第一位出现在美国现行货币正面的女性。安德鲁·杰克逊将保留在纸币的一侧，而哈莉特·塔布曼将在另一侧。这一品牌重塑是在巴拉克·奥巴马总统任期的最后一年宣布的。随后，当时的总统候选人唐纳德·特朗普
The announcement about the $20 bill redesign was made in April 2016. Harriet Tubman, who helped more than 300 slaves find freedom through the Underground Railroad, will be the new face of the $20 bill. Tubman will be the first woman featured on the front of US current. Andrew Jackson will remain on one side of the bill, and Harriet Tubman would be on the other. The rebranding was announced during President Barack Obama's final year in office. Then, presidential candidate Donald Trump
称这一决定是“纯粹的政治正确”。他在NBC的《今日秀》节目中被问及重新设计的问题。我认为哈莉特·塔布曼太棒了。我很愿意留下安德鲁·杰克逊，看看我们是否能想出另一个面额。也许我们做2美元纸币。在宣布重新设计不到一年后，唐纳德·特朗普成为了总统。在椭圆形办公室里，他挂了一幅他最喜欢的前任的画像。那是安德鲁·杰克逊。
called the decision pure political correctness. He was asked about the redesign on NBC's Today Show. I think Harriet Tubman is fantastic. I would love to leave Andrew Jackson and see if we can maybe come up with another denomination. Maybe we do the $2 bill. Less than a year after the redesign was announced, Donald Trump became president. In the Oval Office, he hung a portrait of his favorite predecessor. It was Andrew Jackson.
而在2019年夏天……安德鲁·杰克逊暂时保留了他在20美元纸币上的位置，根据财政部长史蒂芬·姆努钦的说法，他的部门负责监督货币设计。特朗普政府在预计发行该纸币的前几个月搁置了重新设计。对重新设计的最终决定很可能是未来另一位财政部长的事。所以看起来这个项目目前处于搁置状态，我们将拭目以待事情的发展。
And in the summer of 2019... Andrew Jackson is keeping his place on the $20 bill for now that's according to Treasury Secretary Stephen Mnuchin whose department oversees the design of currency. The Trump administration tabled the redesign just months before the bill was expected to be released. The ultimate decision on the redesign will most likely be another secretaries down the road. So it seems like the project is on hold right now, and we'll see how things develop.
无论如何，这些纸币将不得不重新设计，因为重新设计的首要原因，那就是防伪。所以我们将拭目以待会发生什么。最近，拜登政府重新启动了将哈莉特·塔布曼印上20美元纸币的计划。据报道，它定于2030年发行。我们在金钱上看到的面孔和场景传达了我们作为国家的价值观。而我们使用金钱的方式传达了作为个体的一些信息。当我给你钱时，我不仅仅是在给你一张纸。我给你的，是我的诺言，我的约束。社会是一个由持续、连续的关系和未结清的债务组成的实体，对吧？债务的结清与未结清，
Regardless, the notes will have to be redesigned because of the overriding reason for which they're redesigned, which is anti-counter-fitting. So we'll see what happens. More recently, the Biden administration has restarted the plan to put Harriet Tubman on the $20 bill. It's reportedly slated to be released in 2030. The faces and scenes we see on our money communicate our values as a nation. And the way we use that money communicates something about us as individuals. When I give you money, I'm not just giving you a piece of paper. I'm giving you my word, my bond. Society is a thing of ongoing, continuous relationships and unsettled debts, right? The settling and unsettling of debts,
没完没了，没完没了，没完没了。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。几年前，经济学家乔尔·沃尔福格尔写了一篇论文。它的题目是《圣诞节的无谓损失》。他认为，我送给你你不喜欢的礼物，你送给我我不喜欢的礼物，这毫无意义。我们两个最好都保留自己的钱，花在真正喜欢的东西上。人类学家比尔·莫尔对经济学家看待金钱世界的方式有许多异议。乔尔·沃尔福格尔的论点可能是这一切的原点。
on and on and on and on and on. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Some years ago, the economist Joel Walfogal wrote a paper. It was titled, The Dead Weight Loss of Christmas. He argued that it made no sense for me to give you gifts that you don't like and for you to give me gifts that I don't like. We would both be better off keeping our money and spending it on the things we do like. Anthropologist Bill Mora has many disputes with how economists see the world of money. Joa Wallfogel's argument might be ground zero.
我认为经济学家总是想象的一件事是，交易的目的是让它们得到结清，对吧？我们进入债务关系，然后我们想要结清该债务。所以你在店里递给我某样东西，我在收银台给你钱，然后就结束了，接着我们各走各路。他们喜欢那种无摩擦市场的愿景，即各方匿名来到市场，
I think one of the things that economists are always imagining is that the end of transactions is to have them settled, right? That we enter a relationship of debt, and then we want to settle that debt. So you hand me over something at the store, and I give you money at the till, and then it's over, and then we go our separate ways. They love that kind of vision of the frictionless market where parties come to the market anonymously
金钱是调解他们关系的媒介，这样他们就可以继续匿名生活下去。问题是，如果你想象一个所有债务都已结清的世界，那么那是一个怎样的世界？那将是一个没有更多关系、没有更多互惠、没有更多义务的世界。社会不是一个结清债务的社会。社会是一个由持续、连续的关系和未结清的债务组成的实体，对吧？债务的结清与未结清，没完没了，没完没了，没完没了。没有哪个时刻它会结束，或者至少如果有一个它结束的时刻，我们
and money is the thing that mediates their relationship so that then they continue to go on anonymously. The problem is that if you imagine a world where all debts are settled, then what is that world? That's a world then of no more relationships, of no more mutuality, of no more obligation. Society is not a society of settled debts. Society is a thing of ongoing, continuous relationships and unsettled debts, right? The settling and unsettling of debts on and on and on and on and on. There's no moment where it ends, or at least if there was a moment where it ended, we'd
都会独自呆在掩体里躲藏，什么也不做。所以我想知道，这是否与我们看到的一些非常有趣的现象有关，那就是，即使在发明了金钱这个非凡的发明之后，我们也想出了许多让金钱变得低效且难以使用的方法。因此，我们送给朋友餐厅礼品卡，在某种程度上限制了他们如何使用这笔钱。在某种程度上，直接给他们现金会更容易，他们可以在餐厅使用它，或者不在餐厅使用它。
all just be alone in bunkers hiding, doing nothing. So I'm wondering if this is connected to some very interesting phenomena that we see, which is that even after coming up with this remarkable invention, money, we've also come up with lots of ways to make money inefficient and difficult to use. So we give our friends gift cards to restaurants that limit in some ways how they can use the money. In some ways it would be easier just to give them cash and they could use it at the restaurant or not use it at the restaurant.
这些低效的货币形式向我们揭示了金钱在人际关系中扮演着什么角色？是的，我喜欢这类东西，因为它真正向你展示了金钱永远绝非纯粹可替代的，对吧？我们不断地在不同的资金池周围设置界限，而这些界限通常是道德界限。它们标志着我们想要针对彼此采取的道德、伦理或关系立场。
What do these inefficient forms of money tell us about the role that money plays in personal relationships? Yeah, I love this kind of stuff because it really shows you that money is never purely fungible, right? We're continuously putting boundaries around different pots of money, and those boundaries are often moral boundaries. They signify a moral or ethical or relational stance that we want to take with respect to one another.
这种为了特殊目的而对金钱进行标记的做法，这种将一些金钱隔离起来、将其带出流通并保存在特殊地方仅用于特殊目的的做法，确实帮助我们构建了社会生活的素材，帮助我们将彼此缝合在一起，并以远超将金钱视为中性交换媒介的想象力的方式将我们彼此绑定。
And this kind of earmarking of money for special purposes, this kind of sequestering of some money, taking it out of circulation and keeping it in a special place for only a special purpose, really does help us make the stuff of social life, helps us stitch ourselves together and bind us to one another in ways that far exceed the imagination of money as just a neutral medium of exchange.
这两种金钱模型之间的紧张关系——经济学家模型和人类学家模型，存在于我们每个人的内心。如果没有将金钱视为匿名交换的中性形式的能力，我们就无法作为经济行为者发挥作用。当然，我们所有人都凭直觉理解债务和义务是如何运作的，当这两个模型彼此冲突时，我们有时会感到不舒服。例如，几十年来，我们在照顾孩子、家务劳动或照顾年迈父母等耗时且困难的活动上面临着挑战。
The tensions between these two models of money, between the economist model and the anthropologist model, exist within each of us. We couldn't function as economic actors without the capacity to think of money as a neutral form of anonymous exchange. Of course, all of us also intuitively understand how debts and obligations work, and we sometimes become uncomfortable when these two models collide with one another. For example, we have struggled for decades with the challenge of time-consuming and difficult activities like parenting or domestic work or caring for aging parents.
我们应该把这些事情视为工作，给它们贴上金钱的标签，还是某些事情应该存在于金钱领域之外？这可以说是当代西方社会现代主体的一个悖论，那就是我们认为自己首先是个人，其次才是关系的成员，尽管当然，只有通过关系我们才得以形成，对吧？如果不是因为我父母之间的关系，我就不会存在，如果我周围没有一个教我语言的人群网络，我现在就无法和你说话，对吧？是谁教我在世界上如何生存以及如何成为一个建立联系的人。然而，因为我们有这样一种意识形态，
Should we think of these things as jobs, put a dollar figure on them, or should some things exist outside the sphere of money? This is kind of a paradox of modern subjects in contemporary Western societies, is that we think of ourselves as individuals first and members of relationships second, even though of course it's only through relationships that we get formed, right? I wouldn't exist if it were not for a relationship between my parents and I wouldn't be able to be speaking to you now if there weren't a network of folks around me who taught me language, right? Who taught me how to be in the world and how to be a person that makes connections. And yet because we have this
即我们每个人都是一个新人，我们每个人都孤立存在，我们是自己独立的代理人。我们忘记了那些关系，而当这些事情被提出来时，我们有时会对它们感到有点“呃”，对吧？我不想成为那样的人。我不想建立那种联系。我不想被你束缚。我听说你的生活安排有些不寻常。我想知道你能否跟我讲讲，然后聊聊嵌入在你住房中的一些关系。当然。好吧，免责声明，我不是嬉皮士，我们也不是部落，但我与我的伴侣和另一对已婚夫妇住在一起。我们四个人住在一起，而另一
kind of ideology that we are each a new person, we each stand alone, we are our own autonomous agent. We forget about those relationships and when those things are brought forward, we feel sometimes a little, ugh, about them, right? I don't want to be that. I don't want to have that connection. I don't want to be tied to you. I understand that you have a somewhat unusual living arrangement. I'm wondering if you can tell me a little bit about it, then talk about some of the relationships that are embedded in your housing. Sure. Okay, disclaimer, I am not a hippie and we are not a tribe, but I live with my partner and another married couple. There are four of us together and the other
这种意识形态认为我们每个人都是一个全新的人，我们各自独立，是自主的个体。我们忘记了那些关系，而当这些事情被提出来时，我们有时会觉得有点……呃，不太舒服，对吧？我不想成为那样。我不想有那种联系。我不想和你有牵绊。我明白你的居住安排有些特别。我想知道你能不能稍微谈谈它，然后讲讲你住所里蕴含的一些人际关系。当然。好吧，声明一下，我不是嬉皮士，我们也不是部落，但我与我的伴侣和另一对已婚夫妇住在一起。我们四个人生活在一起，另外
couple has a young son. And before their child was born, we became very close friends. We were living a few blocks away from each other. We ended up kind of eating at each other's houses every night, you know, a kind of close, close little network of friends. And I live in Southern California, it's very expensive. We are four professionals, but even with four professional salaries, we felt that, you know, we couldn't necessarily have the kind of house that we wanted.
这对夫妻有一个小儿子。在他们的孩子出生前，我们成了非常要好的朋友。我们住在彼此隔着几个街区的地方。最后我们差不多每天晚上都在对方家里吃饭，你知道的，这是一种亲密无间的小型朋友圈。我住在南加州，这里的物价非常高。我们有四位专业人士，但即便拿着四份专业人士的薪水，我们还是觉得，你知道的，我们不一定能买到那种我们想要的房子。
So we thought, you know, we're kind of eating together all the time anyway and doing everything together. That's by a house together. And you know, sometimes you just sort of make these decisions and you don't know if they're good or bad or what. But we jumped in, we spent, you know, a year looking for a place with sort of two flats, but with an interior staircase.
所以我们想，反正我们不管怎样都经常聚在一起吃饭，而且什么事都在一起做。那就一起买套房吧。你知道，有时你做出这些决定时，并不知道它们是好是坏，或者会怎么样。但我们还是决定试一试，你知道的，我们花了整整一年时间寻找一套带有两个单元但内部有楼梯相连的房子。
So it feels more like one, one big house. They gave birth to their son Carter and we all moved in together and we've been living together now for I guess 13 years maybe more. And you know, as someone who sort of studies money and economic relationships, if I take a step back and look at my own situation, it's kind of interesting because we don't actually have any kind of internal system of accounting. We own the house as tenants in common. We share the mortgage, so we split the mortgage down the middle. At tax time, we split the interest
所以它感觉更像是一个、一个大房子。他们的儿子卡特出生了，我们所有人都搬到了一起，我想我们现在已经一起生活了大概 13 年，甚至更久。而且你知道的，作为一个研究金钱和经济关系的人，如果我退一步看看我自己的处境，这其实挺有意思的，因为我们实际上没有任何内部的记账系统。我们作为共同房主拥有这栋房子。我们分摊房贷，也就是把房贷对半平分。到了报税季，我们把利息
down the middle for filing our taxes. But other than that, we're basically sharing all of our expenses and just kind of living that way. There's no there's no mental accounting really. There's no, you know, I paid for the groceries this week, so you do it next week We're just comfortable doing that and and operating as a kind of larger economic unit and yeah I mean we really are kind of living in a sort of alternative economic arrangement that's based on these you know close I think you could almost call them kin relationships these, you know, close, I think you could almost call them kin relationships that we've established together.
平分用来报税。但除此之外，我们基本上是共享所有的开支，就这样生活着。真的没有什么心理账目。没有什么，你知道的，‘我这周买菜了，所以下周该你了’这种说法，我们很习惯这样做，并作为一个更大的经济整体来运转。是的，我的意思是，我们确实在某种程度上生活在一种另类的经济安排中，这种安排建立在这些，你知道的，关系密切的——我想你几乎可以称之为亲属关系的——我们共同建立的这种关系之上。
And in many ways, like the house is the symbol of those relationships, right? I mean, the house is our shell valuable, right? It's the thing that signifies that connection. So what's so interesting about this arrangement is in some ways it speaks to what you said some time ago by the difference between the way economists want to think about transactions and the way that you're describing them, which is that
在许多方面，这栋房子就是这些关系的象征，对吧？我的意思是，这栋房子就是我们的价值外壳，对吧？它是标志着这种联系的事物。所以这种安排最有趣的地方在于，它在某种程度上印证了你前段时间说过的话，关于经济学家想要看待交易的方式与你所描述的方式之间的区别，也就是
if you want to live in a world where the transaction is over, you know, you give me something, I pay you something, we shake hands, we never see each other again. That is not the system that you have set up for your housing, right? Because your system that you've set up is a system in some ways of indefinite debts and obligations that are constantly being created and repaid. You're constantly engaged in gift giving, gift taking, but that binds you in some ways in a web of obligations that I'm hearing you say in some ways has worked very well for you. It's worked very well. You know, we actually had an anthropologist want to come live with us. I said no She's like I would really love to study this. This is fascinating. No, you can't live in our house
如果你想生活在一个交易已经结束的世界里，你知道的，你给我一些东西，我付给你钱，我们握手，然后就再也见不到彼此了。那并不是你为你的住房所建立的系统，对吧？因为你所建立的系统在某种程度上是一个无限债务和义务的系统，这些债务和义务在不断地产生和偿还。你不断地参与送礼和收礼，但这在某种程度上将你束缚在一个义务网中，我听到你说，这种方式在某些方面对你们非常有效。非常有效。你知道，我们其实曾有一位人类学家想来和我们一起住。我说不，她好像说：‘我真的很想研究这个。这太迷人了。’我说不行，你不能住在我们家。
So in other words the anthropologist doesn't like it when other anthropologists come in and want to study the first anthropologist The anthropologist finds it amusing when others want to do so just finds it amusing when others want to do so. Bill Morrer is an anthropologist at the University of California Irvine. He's the author of How Would You Like to Pay and other works about the nature and origin of money. Bill, thanks for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much, Shankar. I've enjoyed it. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Brigitte McCarthy, Annie Murphy Paul, Laura Correll, Kristen Wong, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes and
换句话说，当其他人类学家进来并想研究这位人类学家时，这位人类学家并不喜欢这样。这位人类学家只是觉得当别人想这么做时很有趣。比尔·莫雷尔（Bill Maurer）是加州大学欧文分校的人类学家。他是《你想怎么付款》以及其他关于金钱本质与起源的著作的作者。比尔，谢谢你今天来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢你，尚卡尔（Shankar）。我很高兴。《隐藏的大脑》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布丽吉特·麦卡锡（Brigitte McCarthy）、安妮·墨菲·保罗（Annie Murphy Paul）、劳拉·科雷尔（Laura Correll）、克里斯滕·王（Kristen Wong）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）以及
Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Some of our best ideas on the show come from conversations we have with friends. That's why our unsung hero this week is Dominique Munios. He gave us the idea to explore the story of Harriet Tubman and the $20 bill. Thank you Dominique. Next week in our Money 2.0 series, the psychology of inequality. That awkward moment standing in the lunch line suddenly increased my awareness of not only the inequality in my classroom, but the implications of what it meant to be one of the poor kids. We're working on a story about people who claim to be someone they were not. Have you ever hung a disabled person parking for a metron your car when you didn't really need one?
安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。节目中一些最好的创意都来自于我们与朋友的对话。这就是为什么我们这周的无名英雄是多米尼克·穆尼奥斯（Dominique Munios）。他给了我们灵感，去探索哈莉特·塔布曼（Harriet Tubman）与 20 美元纸币的故事。谢谢你，多米尼克。下周在我们的“金钱 2.0”系列中，我们将探讨不平等的心理学。站在午餐队伍中那种尴尬的时刻突然增强了我对课堂上不平等现象的意识，不仅如此，我还意识到了作为一个贫穷孩子意味着什么的含义。我们正在制作一个关于那些声称自己并非某种人的人的故事。你有没有在不需要的时候，把残疾人停车证挂在车上？
Have you ever claimed to be a member of a disadvantaged group in order to get ahead? Have you ever invented an entire story about a traumatic past just to a illicit sympathy? If you're willing to share your own personal story with us, record a short voice memo on your phone and email it to us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, making it up. If you prefer, we can share your story with the hidden brain audience without using your name. Again, record a short voice memo on your phone and email it to us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org using the subject line, making it up. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. using the subject line making it up. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你有没有为了出人头地而声称自己是弱势群体的一员？你有没有为了博取同情而凭空捏造一个关于痛苦过去的完整故事？如果你愿意与我们分享你自己的个人故事，请在手机上录制一封简短的语音备忘录，并将其通过电子邮件发送给我们：ideas@hiddenbrain.org。使用主题行：胡编乱造（making it up）。如果你愿意，我们可以在不透露你名字的情况下与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享你的故事。再次强调，请在手机上录制一封简短的语音备忘录，并将其通过电子邮件发送给我们：ideas@hiddenbrain.org，主题行使用：胡编乱造。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。回头见。使用主题行：胡编乱造。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。回头见。这集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。